vivir sin saber cuándo caerá la próxima
bomba es por todo esto que se puede
entender la dimensión de lo que han
tenido que padecer en Ucrania los
habitantes y esto ha tenido afectaciones
en la Salud Mental para hablar de ese
tema nos acompaña nuestra periodista
especializada en salud más Romero
salamar bienvenida un placer estar con
usted muchas gracias a todos Bueno mar
quiero que nos cuente Ya vimos los
impactos Hannah Nos daba un avance de lo
que es vivir bajo las bombas veíamos
esto también Cómo afecta el deporte pero
en general la guerra que ha
desencadenado en la Salud Mental pues
definitivamente ha sido una de las
principales Víctimas de la guerra lo
tenemos eso lo podemos dar por seguro y
queríamos destacar que quizás este
conflicto en Ucrania ha sido una de las
primeras veces en que realmente se ha
abordado este tema con tanto
protagonismo no ha sido de las primeras
veces que desde el inicio de que
empezara la invasión rusa hemos tenido
en cuenta eso para la cobertura
periodística las agencias
internacionales de salud lo han tenido
en cuenta se ha hecho hincapié una de
las cosas que debatíamos por ejemplo
entre nosotros es que podía tener que
ver con la pandemia no la pandemia en
2020 fue un gran catalizador Para darle
protagonismo para poder tener estos
debates alrededor de la importancia de
la Salud Mental que muchas veces ha
quedado relegada por detrás de la salud
o de los impactos físicos y más en unas
zonas de conflicto o en un momento de
tanta urgencia como puede ser una guerra
pero ahora sabemos eso que
definitivamente puede dejar heridas tan
profundas como las físicas y que además
la Salud Mental especialmente tiene una
capacidad de afectar a personas que no
necesariamente tienen que estar en
primera línea de frente para entender
mejor esas implicaciones entrevistamos a
Pepe Fernández Díaz que es el presidente
de médicos del mundo escuchémoslo como
consecuencia de la situación de
conflicto está todo el daño en la Salud
Mental que es muy importante y muy
extendido en la población en las zonas
donde el conflicto ha tenido mayor
intensidad ahí es imposible estimar
una cifra pero seguro que son decenas de
miles de personas las que sufren por
ejemplo este es postraumático
trastornos de ansiedad y otras neurosis
trastornos del sueño y también el
agravamiento de estos procesos más
prolongados que las personas ya vienen
sufriendo anteriormente
mar se habla de decenas de miles de
personas afectadas Pero hay cifras sobre
el impacto en la Salud Mental que ha
tenido la guerra pues como lo decía el
presidente de médicos del mundo es muy
difícil tener exactamente las cifras
ahora mismo sobre Cuántas personas Esto
está afectando en Ucrania pero sin
embargo la Organización Mundial de la
Salud sí publicó recientemente unas
estimaciones se basaron en cifras que ya
se conocen sobre las afectaciones a la
Salud Mental en zonas de conflicto y se
calcula que el 22% de la población sufre
algún impacto sobre su salud mental y un
9% tiene afecciones moderadas o graves
su salud mental si esto se aplica en
Ucrania vemos que estamos hablando de
más de 9 millones de personas que están
sufriendo de alguno en tipo de
afectación sobre su salud mental y que
casi 4 millones tiene una afectación
grave o moderada son cifras bastante
grandes que deberían hacernos
reflexionar bueno Y cuál es ese impacto
diferenciado que se tiene dependiendo de
qué tan cerca se esté del conflicto
claro no es lo mismo estar en el este
que en el oeste de Ucrania más en las
zonas de conflicto o más alejado en
zonas como kiev olbid no es lo mismo
estar en el centro que estar desplazado
no Entonces estos son algunos de las
diferencias que tenemos entre unos y
otros por ejemplo la guerra en Sí suele
tener manifestaciones estar presente en
la línea de frente suele tener
manifestaciones como trastornos de
estrés postraumático que afecta
mayoritariamente por ejemplo a los
hombres que mayoritariamente acuden a
las líneas de frente Mientras que el
desplazamiento la mayoría de refugiadas
recordemos son mujeres tienen suelen
tener más manifestaciones de ansiedad
depresión o estrés crónico también según
más cerca estemos del epicentro digamos
eso sucede también en los trastornos en
los perdón en los desastres naturales no
Cuanto más cerca más graves pueden ser
esas afectaciones Cuanto más lejos más
leves pero eso como decíamos antes no
significa que no puedan haber
afectaciones Incluso en otros países que
esta conflicto no haya generado
ansiedades o trastornos afectaciones en
gente que vive de Lejos de nuevo le
preguntábamos lo mismo a Pepe Martínez
en las zonas donde se han producido
ataques directos Pues claro es obvio que
todo el impacto
ya no el impacto directo de los misiles
o de las Bombas o
de las balas en los edificios que
también sino pues todo el cortejo que
comportan el estar Bajo La amenaza y
bajo alarmas y alertas continuadas en la
población que tiene que acudir a
refugios o a lugares de acogida pues ahí
también se va acumulando una carga de
estrés de ansiedad de cualquier tipo de
neurosis que va acumulativamente dañando
mucho la Salud Mental bueno Omar y
siempre uno de los problemas que
obstaculiza no abordar este tipo de
temas es el estigma que que pesa sobre
la Salud Mental sobre los problemas no
en la Salud Mental sobre todo Sí Santi
tienes toda la razón eso sucede en
ucranias probablemente suceden muchos de
los rincones del mundo pero varias
organizaciones lo han nombrado como uno
de los problemas a la hora de abordar
esto Precisamente en este conflicto y
más en un momento en que quizás abordar
la Salud Mental no es una de las
prioridades dentro de todas las cosas
que se tienen que atender esto nos
decían desde médicos del mundo porque el
peso del estigma de los problemas de
Salud Mental hace que la gente se
retraiga mucho de verbalizarlos de
expresarlos de exponerlos de
visibilizarlos y sin embargo el daño
está ahí si algo ocultamos son nuestros
trastornos de la Esfera mental y
psicológica
si algo ocultamos es
no nos importa decir que tomamos un
antiinflamatorio un analgésico un
antitérmico pero si no os importa
comentar de forma abierta que podamos
tomar ansiolítico precisamente fuimos a
buscar cifras sobre este estigma
encontramos un estudio del instituto
global mental Health de Cambridge prince
de 2021 que tenía cifras bastante
reveladoras mientras un 73% de la
población ucraniana había respondido que
debería haber más aceptación
precisamente sobre problemas de Salud
Mental había muchas opiniones y muchos
comportamientos muy estigmatizantes por
ejemplo más de tres cuartos de la
población creía que una persona con
algún trastorno mental no debería
gobernar algo que probablemente No
sucedería si el problema es diabetes de
una enfermedad cardiovascular no más de
un 80% creía que un paciente con Salud
Mental con algún problema de Salud
Mental abro comillas Debería ser
disciplinado como un niño Esa era la
frase que se preguntaba y casi la mitad
creían que un paciente de Salud Mental
Debería ser hospitalizado que eso a
veces en ocasiones es cierto pero no
tiene por qué ser así entonces vemos si
desde aquí partíamos en 2021 Pues todo
esto sigue vivo en la base Pues en la
sociedad ucraniana Y probablemente
dificulta que se aborden estos problemas
Bueno y no solo la gran pregunta es el
estigma que tienen que enfrentar las
personas que están padeciendo
enfermedades de Salud Mental a causa de
la guerra sino qué va a pasar después
porque claramente las consecuencias
también se verán a largo plazo Así es
María Clara y además sabemos que por
ahora no parece probable que termine
pronto esta guerra no hay cerca ningún
tipo de final que es lo que habíamos
hablado aquí también varias veces
entonces claro estos problemas que se
trataban como cosas puntuales
especialmente al inicio de la guerra no
como puede ser una afectación puntual
corre en el riesgo de que se cronifiquen
de que un momento particular de ansiedad
por ejemplo se vuelva en un problema
diagnosticado de ansiedad Crónica y
además todo esto entendiendo que es
posible que todas estas trastornos de
Salud Mental tengan afectaciones en
otros campos de la salud por ejemplo
entendemos que están asociados el estrés
con el aumento de los corticoides el
aumento de los corticoides es malo para
la salud cardiovascular puede hasta
provocar diabetes trastornos de Salud
Mental tienen que ver también con abuso
de sustancias que es probable que suceda
en este tipo de condiciones entonces
bueno Tendremos que seguir muy atentos A
cómo se van resolviendo este tipo de
problemas gracias por estar con nosotros
Muchas gracias a todos